Cramer is curator of collections at the
thorough institute at Walden Woods an
editor of a new fully annotated edition
of Henry VIII sorrows Walden its release
marks the 150th anniversary of the
publication of mr. atheros book on
living in the walden woods of
Massachusetts the stock is 40 minutes
Nathaniel Hawthorne once described Henry
David Thoreau as being quote ugly as sin
yet he qualified this statement by
saying that thorough physical appearance
was entirely suitable given Thoros
rustic lifestyle one certainly finds it
more difficult to imagine the dashing
and welker toward Nathaniel Hawthorne
roughing it or being close to nature in
the way that furrow was fortunately we
are not today here to discuss the
physical physical attributes or
otherwise of henry david thoreau rather
we are here to celebrate and discuss
intellectual achievements not only those
of thorough but particularly of dr. Jeff
Kramer who was written edited this
stunningly Airy diet edition of
Thoreau's Walden Jeffrey S Kramer is an
editor of Walden a fully annotated
edition recently published by yale
university press which is already
getting a lot of attention USA Today
said quote Kramer's side notes are like
short illuminating conversations and the
Boston Globe called it a handsome All
Things Walden edition Jess essays and
other writings have appeared in the
Massachusetts review the literary review
the Christian Science Monitor among
others and have appeared in such
collections as contemporary literary
criticism and the Robert Frost
encyclopedia Jesse's curator of
collections of the warden Ward's
projects Thoreau Institute he's also the
editor of Thoreau on freedom attending
to man selected writings of henry david
thoreau which was published by fulcrum
publishing in 2003
and is currently edition editing a
second volume for Yale entitled what I
lived for an annotated selection from
Thoros journals juelz in 2006 please
join me in welcoming Jeff Kramer today
thanks thank you so nice to see so many
friendly faces and familiar faces here
it's also nice to get a chance to talk
about Walden and center of Walden
country so I appreciate the Concord
bookshop inviting me here the first
question may be why should we living in
a world so different from the world in
which Henry David Thoreau found himself
150 years ago we had all interested in
the words he wrote what possible
relevance could his words have for us
today how can any of the remedies which
he offered in his somewhat provincial
world be useful in the global
environment to which we now find
ourselves when I asked myself these
questions i realized that i do not go to
thorough or to any author for answers i
go for questions and i hope what you may
take away with you today is not the
ability to question what you already
have but the willingness and the desire
to do so edward abbey road an essay
called down the river with henry
thorough ended he described his thoughts
as he read his old worn copy of walden
while he went down a river in Utah
Wendell Berry described Abby's essay in
this way it is an essay in the literal
sense a trial mr. Abby tries himself
against thorough and thorough against
himself he tries himself and thorough
against the river he tries himself and
thorough in the river against modern
times and vice versa this is thorough
this is walding thorough is a writer
against whom we should try ourselves not
not should but against whom we must try
ourselves because he forces us to ask
the questions we do not necessarily want
to hear several years ago I wrote an
essay about homeschooling which there
was a passage which forced the reader in
a way that could not be ignored to
question his or her beliefs about
schooling and I was told by a vehement
homeschooling parent that I couldn't
write what I had written without
offending and perhaps risk
losing some of my readers and they said
but thyroid did that in his essays to
which they answered a year not thorough
and although I know I'm not thorough
what I wonder now is whether what that
person really meant was that we can
accept someone from 150 years ago saying
things which may offend us or may force
us to take a kind of our lives because
we can always relegate that person to a
place of the past place them in history
in a place of ignorance of the trials we
face today but we cannot accept someone
today even if we're Henry thorough come
back forcing us to front the essential
questions and live deliberately this
afternoon I wouldn't talk about
stewarding the spirit of Walden and how
we can truly be stewards of Thoreau's
message and in order to do that I want
to talk for a few minutes about what he
was trying to do in writing Walden when
I ask people who visit me at the
thorough Institute at Walden Woods who
or what there was and this is not trick
question but just a straightforward
question I most often hear words like
naturalist if abolitionists
environmentalist social reformer
transcendentalist but the word I rarely
here and this is the word that comes to
mind first to me when I think about
thorough is writer and so it is
important when reading tharam
particularly rereading Walden that you
bear in mind his intentions working his
way through the writing of Walden
thorough wrote in his journal I too
would fain set down something besides
facts facts should be only as the frame
to my pictures they should be the
material to mythology which I am writing
my facts should be falsehoods to the
common sense i would so state facts that
they shall be significant shall be myths
or mythologic now if you think of myths
has not simply extraordinary stories
about gods and monsters and heroes but
stories that attempt to explain aspects
of the natural world and to delineate
the customs and the ideals and
psychology of society the mythology
mythology was clearly what there was
writing and although we tend to think
myth of myths as traditional stories
floating in time without a clear origin
every ancient story was at one time told
to a living audience hearing it for the
first time reading Walden in any other
way the way it was intended to be
red predisposes the reader to failure so
how should we read Walden to read well
that is to read true books in a true
spirits or a wrote in reading chapter is
a noble exercise and one that will task
the reader more than any exercise which
the customs of the day esteem it
requires a training such as the athletes
underwent the steady intention of all
most of the whole life to this object
books must be read as deliberately and
reservedly as they were written an
approaching walden is the record of one
man stay at walden pond it becomes easy
to join the host of those who find fault
with thorough because he had gender with
the Emerson's or he brought his
laundering home to the hacer family
household but if you read in a thorough
vain way transcendentally you will meet
with the success that many readers of
walden will fail to achieve which
ultimately means that a good book must
not only be written by a good writer but
must be written but must be read by a
good reader thorough is clear in his
purpose when he writes the heroic books
even if printed in the character of our
mother tongue will always be in a
language dead to degenerate times we
must laborious ly seek the meaning of
each word and line conjecturing a larger
sense than common use permits out of
what wisdom and valor and generosity we
have daro is not writing about books
from a distant past he's writing about a
book he was writing to his
contemporaries the book we're talking
about today walden is a heroic book
because it is a book about a hero the
scottish writer Thomas Carlyle once sent
a challenge to Emerson I wish you would
take an American hero one whom you
really love and give us a history of him
consciously or not Sarah took up the
challenge in order to do that thorough
would need to redefine the heroic and
place himself in the role of hero
thorough understood as he would write in
walking that the hero is commonly the
simplest and obscurus of men by turning
the experiment of walden of life into a
heroic task he was able to turn Walden
from a philosophical tract of
unattainable goals into a guide for the
perplexed
he was able to make a representative man
not out of the past but of the present
and he was able to tell the story not
from the outside using third-person
narrative but from the inside using the
pronoun I and so giving his text a sense
of immediacy integrity and strength that
I wrote in his journal and repeated in
his first book a week on the concrete of
merrimack rivers that autobiography is
preferred over biography he said if i am
not i who will be or again in his
journal is not the poet bound to write
his own biography is there any other
work for him but a good journal we do
not wish to know how his imaginary hero
but how he the actual hero lived from
day to day it was the poet's business he
wrote to be continually watching the
moods of his mind as the astronomer
watches the aspects of the heavens what
might we not expect from a long life
faithfully spent in this wise as
travelers go around the world and report
natural objects and phenomena so
faithfully let another stay at home and
report the phenomena of his own life
given that it must be remembered that
Walden is a literary work in which
thorough takes liberties with
biographical faithfulness for the sake
of artistic integrity of the work and
the mythic life he's creating and those
liberties allowed thorough to
concentrate on what he sometimes called
his real life differentiating between
this and his actual life but would live
from a day-to-day experience thorough
wrote to his friend Blake that he spoke
from his faith and aspiration and to
another friend he wrote you may rely on
it that you have the best of me in my
books and then I am not worth seeing
personally the stuttering blundering
clodhoppers that I am even poetry you
know is in one sense an infinite brag
and exaggeration not that I do not stand
and all that i have written but what am
I to the truth I feebly utter and to
appreciate that truth with thorough
uttered they take several readings of
the text as he wrote to the Emerson's it
is the height of art that on the first
perusal plain common sense should appear
on the second severe truth and on the
third beauty and having these warrants
for its depths and reality we may then
enjoy that beauty forevermore
thorough was aware that there were as
you wrote in a week manifold visions in
the direction of every object being the
deliberate artist he was that I wrote in
his journal and what reads like a
reminder to himself improve the
opportunity opportunity to draw
analogies there are innumerable avenues
to our perception of the truth this was
so integral to thur ohs perception of
the world around him that once just
seeing ice on the river he asked himself
in his journal what's the analogy the
answer sometimes required distance it
was not often always possible to
immediately appreciate the
correspondence between the things seen
and the things unseen poetry here Oates
rewrote puts an interval between the
impression in the expression waits till
the seed germinates naturally and all
this helps towards an understanding of
what Sarah was doing as you wrote about
the Walden experience but does not
necessarily help with the question of
why you went there and there were many
reasons why he went there some of them
are fairly mundane such as needing time
and quiet to write his first book but
there a couple of broader reasons i just
want touch on the first being the
influence of emerson who is at the
center of the transcendentalist circle
but also many ways the center of the
intellectual circle of his day although
some tend to downplay the influence of
Emerson over the young thorough actually
the roegans downplayed Emersonian
emphasized it it is impossible to think
of thorough without hearing echoes of
Emerson this I think in no way
diminishes thorough but in fact adds
something to an understanding of him in
annotating Walden I found even more than
I had anticipated Kythera was a master
at absorbing what had come before him
and turning it uniquely into his own
that Emerson was an influence on
thorough and a strong one was as it
should be the thorough could take that
influence and adapt it without being
overwhelmed by it was the key to his
strength and individuality Emerson in
1837 presented his oration the American
scholar too thorough as graduating class
at Harvard it's unclear what the
thorough was there and heard it at the
time but he certainly did would have
read it later in pamphlet form the
Emerson home an emerson wrote of the
unfulfilled potential of young americans
in these words young men of the fairest
promise who begin life upon our shoe
inflated by the mountain winds shined
upon by all the stars of God find the
earth below night in unison with ease
but are hindered from action by the
discussed which the principles on which
businesses managed inspire and turn
drudges or die of discussed some of them
suicides what is the remedy they did not
yet see and thousands of young men as
hopeful now crowding to the barriers for
the career do not yet see that if the
single man plant himself indomitable Eon
his instincts and their abide the huge
world will come round to him patience
patience with the shades of all the good
and great for company and for solace the
perspective of your own infinite life
and for work the study and the
communication of principles the making
those instincts prevalent the conversion
of the world is it not the chief
disgraced in the world not to be a unit
not to be reckoned one character not to
yield that peculiar fruit which each man
was created to bear we will walk on our
own feet we will work with our own hands
will speak our own minds imagine the
power of those words on a young man who
is still searching still trying to find
out who he was what he was about imagine
the power of those words as a call to
arms a clarion call or call like the
crowing of Chanticleer waking his
neighbors up an emerson wrote further in
the same essay that the ancient precept
know thyself and the modern precept
study nature become at last one maxim
and so the idea was confirmed for
thorough that understanding nature was
paralleled understanding yourself that
through a close examination of the
exterior life you could discern the
interior life another reason for going
to Walden Pond was the challenge
suggested to him by the utopian
communities springing up in the early
1840s and in particular the two with
which some of our was friends were
closely associated Brook Farm and fruit
lands George Ripley one of the
cofounders of Brook Farm explained that
they were trying to prepare and i quote
a society of liberal intelligent and
cultivated persons whose relations with
each other would permit a more simple
and wholesome life than can be led
amidst the pressure of our competitive
institutions if wisely executed it will
be a light over this country and this
age
thorough was conducting the same
experiment in living that these
communities were but on a smaller scale
and from a different direction he was
not trying to recreate society by
reinventing how a community should work
or by imposing a new constitution as
Brook Farm had done upon a self-created
communal Association this was not the
way society would be renewed and the
failure of these and other similar
experiments to fundamentally change the
way people live showed that there was
correct in searching for another method
to reform human culture thorough
question the individuals role and
obligations not just society only but to
himself how should he live how should he
interact with his neighbors how should
he obligate himself to the laws not of a
society with within which he lived but
to those laws which are higher than
those of the land moral or religious
principles or laws of conscious that
take precedence over the Constitution's
or statutes of society and so when his
friend Ellery Channing jokingly said to
him I see nothing for you in this earth
but that field which I once christened
briars go out upon that build yourself a
Hut and their begin the grand process of
devouring yourself alive thera was ready
and he believed that to succeed one has
to be predisposed and susceptible toward
that success only that day dawns to
which we are awake he wrote in the final
paragraph of Walden or as he wrote in a
post Walden journal entry I think we may
detect the some sort of preparation and
faint expectation preceded every
discovery that we have made my
expectation ripens to discovery I am
prepared for strange things it was
through this infinite expectation of the
dawn as he called it in Walden that we
are in a position of allowing ourselves
to be prepared to be open and ready to
see wonders no method nor discipline
Thoreau wrote can supersede the
necessity of being forever on the alert
and earlier hero also involved in moral
reform is the effort to throw off sleep
in 1851 Sarah was reading a book by a
man named james wilkinson entitled the
human body in its connection to man
Wilkinson's book Thoreau wrote in his
journal to some extent realizes what I
have dreamed of his ability to trace
analogies often leads to a truer word
the more remarkable writers have found
the
faith he puts in old and current
expressions as having sprung from an
instinct wiser than science and safely
to be trusted if they can be interpreted
all perception of truth is the distinct
is the detection of an analogy we reason
from our hands to our heads
understanding this was a confirmation of
what thorough was trying to do in Walden
because it was through analogy that we
begin to comprehend the correspondence
between the physical and the spiritual
and to truly understand that nature is
not something outside of us but that we
and nature are the same it was this
analogous nature of his writings that
led to his grievance in the conclusion
to Walden that in some part of the world
parts of the world it is considered a
ground for complaint if a man's writing
admit of more than one interpretation
and it was around this time 1851 that he
began to turn a history of myself which
is what there were called his early
lectures about the Walden experience
into Walden when the I change from the
personal pronoun to a representation of
every man or the every person or the
possibilities would be every person
although Thoreau wrote about the
predominance of the pronoun I in his
text in fact the compositor sometimes
ran out of the capital letter when
setting type for the book it would be a
mistake to treat thorough examination of
his life is self-involved or even
strictly self-serving because it's
through observing the self that we can
observe society it is through the me
that we can understand the not me and is
by way of the individual that the world
can be changed some readers are troubled
by thurs insistence on individual reform
as if he were somehow withdrawing from
or abandoning the societal issues which
plagued his day but that would be to
invalidate a thorough and others of
extended contemporaries believed it was
through the reform of the one that the
many would be reformed for a community
or society is merely a group of
individuals trying to live in harmony
with each other and so if the individual
is reformed societal reform would be a
natural consequence a year and a half
before moving to walden thorough wrote
we must first succeed alone that when
they enjoy our success together self
emancipation was what thorough called it
in his early journal entries that's what
he was looking for and this was only a
step toward a greater and more Universal
liberation
because when any one person makes a
conscious decision to act or to refrain
from acting then that decision puts
every one of us in the position of
making a choice deliberately mindfully
and willfully when one person signs off
from a church as thorough had done the
knows who remain do so by choice whether
they realize it or not when one person
refuses to pay a tax or to submit to the
draft or to eat meat the knows who do
pay the tax or go to war or eat me do so
consciously because the ability to do
otherwise has been made explicit I know
of no more encouraging fact there were
wrote in Walden then in unquestionable
ability of man to elevate his life by a
conscious endeavor Walden gives us
options and once having read the book we
are no longer allowed the luxury of
ignorance Daria does not tell us to live
the way he did but only to accept such
portions of his work that replied to
each of us individually as he wrote I
trust that none will stretch the seams
and putting on the coat for it may do
good service to Him whom it fits when he
what he's telling us to do and this
would perhaps when the most central
messages in walden is to be aware of our
choices to be deliberate to be awake and
to do that we must ask ourselves the
same questions that thorough asked
himself what he asked to use the words
of the Catechism is the chief end of man
and what are the true necessaries and
means of life to answer those questions
thorough ahead to delve deeply if time
as he wrote is but a stream and a stream
which he knew to be shallow then he had
to be willing to let time go to find a
timelessness beyond to find that which
is eternal thorough had to search for
the fundamental facts and existence of
existence and separate the real from the
actual in other words the task which he
set for himself was to find the reality
which transcended his day-to-day
experiences on this distinction between
the real or the ideal and the actual
thorough wrote in his journal some
incidents in my life has seen far more
allegorical than actual they were so
significant that they plainly served no
other purpose but this search for the
real was not just a literary exercise
providing him with tropes and Ally
gories for his writings although I
certainly served this end also but it
was and I don't use these words lightly
a sacred quest for the miracle which
daily fronted him life nature spirit
this is what in part separated the
transcendentalist from those who
accepted the standard of spiritual
spiritual servitude coming out of
Harvard and it was servitude because it
placed the mass of people under the
leadership of a few and it was through
these authorities or persons who spoke
from a position of authority for served
almost as intermediaries that people
were led to God or spirit or the
Oversoul or whatever term you want to
use and it was through them that went
found salvation or redemption in
describing the woodcutter in Walden in
whom the spiritual man was slumbering as
an infant sorrow was describing his
neighbors estero wrote of the woodcutter
he had been instructed only in that
innocent and ineffectual way in which
the Catholic priests teach the
Aborigines by which the pupil is never
educated to the degree of consciousness
but owing to the degree of trust and
reverence and a child is not made a man
but kept a child thorough wanted us to
wake to a degree of consciousness that
took us beyond trust in and reverence
for the authority to trust in and
reverence for the original source do you
not hear about miracles from a distant
biblical past but to experience the
miracle of the day there is no
interpreter he wrote in his journal
between us in our consciousness the
question he asks his readers in Walden
will you'll be a reader a student merely
or a seer is perhaps the most important
question he addresses to us thinking of
those authorities who stand between us
and life itself he wrote what is the
course of history or philosophy or
poetry no matter how well selected or
the best society or the most admirable
routine of life compared with the
discipline of looking always at what is
to be seen when he used a word like seer
thorough meant literally of course one
who sees but he also knew that if or
when you see then you become by
extension what this word seer also means
profit someone who speaks with divine
inspiration this inspiration is what the
transcendental is sometimes called
reason
or by George Ripley defined as the
immediate perception of truth Emerson
explained it this way reason is the
highest Faculty of the soul what we mean
often by the soul itself it never
reasons never proves it simply perceives
it is vision reason is potentially
perfect in every man and because reason
as Emerson said is potentially perfect
in every one of us we owe it to
ourselves to pay attention to this
intuitive truth many of Thoreau's
lectures lectures like slavery in
Massachusetts or life without principle
which are written about the same time
thorough is writing Walden user fierce
almost fire and brimstone language are
impart invectives using the tone of the
reformed lecture circuit in which the
lecturer sometimes part of the clergy
but often not sought to introduce moral
reform in such areas as temperance and
education and women's rights abolition
and like many of their church-going
contemporaries theros audience expected
to be surmised to and shouted at with a
thundering voice of the pulpit that they
were going to hell and be told in no
uncertain terms of all the ways they
were breaking God's commandments but the
spirit of walden is of a different
nature and although there are passages
which are quite blunt much of the
writing in walden is subtle wooing
humorous poetically soaring and exalted
and ultimately demanding demanding
because it needs time to be absorbed in
a culture we like to be spoon-fed our
knowledge and very small bites of
information even doing what you're doing
this afternoon listening to someone
speak for a half an hour on one topic
can be challenging no matter how when
throwing the topic or the speaker so to
pick up a book that maybe should carry
some sort of warning label is also a
challenge but one worth labe one worth
taking if you're ready if you're up to
the task how many a man has dated a new
era in his life from the reading of a
book Sarah Rodin Walden perhaps
understanding at this point what it was
he was actually creating the book exists
for us perchance he went on to say which
will explain our miracles and reveal new
ones the at present unutterable things
we may find somewhere uh turd these same
questions that disturb and puzzle and
confound us have been there turn
occurred to all the wise men not why
has been omitted and each has answered
them according to his ability by his
words and his life moreover with wisdom
we shall learn liberality perhaps when
he lost his brother John or became
disappointed in Emerson perhaps what he
needed most was a confirmation of his
own belief in the heroic individual and
so he made himself into the
transcendental hero he sought to live
right to do right and to perhaps cause
others to do so also was a goal worth
striving for in the where I lived in
what I lived for chapter thorough wrote
it is something to be able to paint a
particular picture or the Carver statue
and so to make a few objects beautiful
but it is far more glorious to carve and
paint the very atmosphere and medium
through which we look which morally we
can do to affect the quality of the day
that is the highest of Arts thorough
lived in hard times when everything that
he believed in and everything for which
his country stood was being challenged
we live in hard times of a different
character when our country is being
divided politically morally and
ethically and during times of hardship
danger it is increasingly difficult to
focus on to use the terms thorough would
have used the real when we were so
attentive to the actual or to put it in
different words it is easy to be alert
to the transient and to be inattentive
to the permanent although he would not
have said it this way thorough knew as
many of us do not that to be politically
correct is not the same as being morally
or ethically correct and he knew that
there were higher laws to which every
human being was obligated in one sense
walden is a book about freedom if we're
willing to fall away in which thero
takes us beyond the concept of our
common understanding of slavery as a
forced servitude to include the many
ways in which we are all maybe
potentially enslaved society religion
economics fear and Prejudice the economy
chapter in particular tells us in no
uncertain terms that we are not free
what would the man believed what would
the man who believed we should work one
day per week and rest six think of
today's society in which so many of us
believe not only that we can't possibly
economically by following thurs tenant
but that we're actually obliged to have
two salaries to make ends meet thinking
in those terms and bearing in mind that
the ethic is greater than the action
self emancipation begins to seem a more
altruistic and noble goal I am serene
and satisfied Thoreau wrote when the
birds fly and the fishes swim as in
fable for the moral is not far off when
the migration of the goose is
significant and has a moral to it when
the events of the day have a
mythological character and the most
trivial is symbolized every incident is
a parable of the great teacher there is
method of exacting a truth out of an
experience was told in a November letter
to his friend Blake regarding a recent
excursion Blake had taken up Mount
Washington they want to read you a
somewhat long passage because it's so
crucial I think to an understanding of
walden thorough wrote to Blake let me
suggest a theme to you to stay to
yourself precisely and completely what
that walk over the mountains amounted to
for you returning to this essay again
and again until you are satisfied that
all that was important in your
experience is in it give this good
reason to yourself for having gone over
the mountain for mankind is ever going
over a mountain don't suppose that you
can tell it precisely the first dozen
times you try but Adam again especially
when after sufficient pause you suspect
that you are touching the heart or
summit of the matter read it reiterate
your blows there and account for the
mountain to yourself not that the story
need be long but it will take a long
while to make it short it did not take
very long to get over the mountain you
thought but have you got over it indeed
if you have been to the top of Mount
Washington let me ask what did you find
there that is the way they prove
witnesses you know going up there being
blown on is nothing we never do much
climbing while we are there but we eat
our lunch and etc very much as at home
it is after we get home that we really
go over the mountain if ever what did
the mountain say why did the mountain
dew that same counsel may be directed to
every reader of Walden it may not take
very long to read the book or to get
over the mountain but then we must ask
ourselves the question have you got over
it indeed what did you find there
thorough is one with whom one wants to
contend with whom one wants to lay claim
and quarrel or go to for confirmation
whether the end result is sanctioned or
censure that we may not live up to the
thorough V an ideal hero is to be
expected and we didn't live up to it
either but he didn't create or recreate
the transcendental hero as an end but
only as a means to compel us to explore
that unexplored country our own lives so
it may at least approximate it in
whatever way we can Walden forces us to
ask questions and because the answers
change not only from generation to
generation but for each individual from
year to year we are still going over the
mountain going back to the pond going
back to the book that 150 years later
walden is still a vital and relevant
text is testimony to the universality of
the parables of a great teacher and a
tribute to the parable maker the seer
and the poet that there was and each of
us every individual here today can as a
personal obligation to steward the
spirit of walden because we each have
within within us the ability to live
heroically or at a paraphrase thorough
to live deliberately to front only the
essential facts of life and see if we
cannot learn what it has to teach and
not when we come to die discover that we
had not lived thank you I think we have
time for a couple of questions if there
are any and you have to wait for the
boom to come overhead if anyone is going
to ask anything yes
right I think the journals are crucial
to an understanding of sorrows life or
any part of thurs life and whatever he
kept working on because the way I look
at the journals is that they were a
place where thorough was trying out
ideas i mean the germ of every idea
shows up in the journals it's
experimenting with with his writings in
the journals and so i don't think you
can really truly understand any of his
works without at least glancing at parts
of the Eternals given that that two
million words it's a little hard for
most people to get through them all but
I think it's worth looking at them
that's not to say you can't approach any
of his works without the journals and I
think they all stand perfectly well on
their own but I think you'll grain to
gain a greater depth of understanding
bite by glancing at them any other
questions yes Henry Henry did throw died
at the age of 44 right from an illness
study that he caught outdoors why he had
tuberculosis and if he would have a
lived longer what what direction was
even thinking than those lost their last
year you know it's really hard to tell
they're there are unfinished manuscripts
he certainly seemed to want to do
something about Native Americans and he
was very very interested in the Native
Americans who inhabited America before
we all came and um you know the idea was
that he probably would have done some
sort of work we have no idea what on
Native Americans he was working on what
he called the calendar or calendar where
he who was studying when all of plans
and various things happen to nature in
the air and you go back year after year
to study when each flower blossomed when
each flower seated and so he certainly
would have done something on a more
scientific level probably later in his
life but it's anybody's guess I mean if
you look at where he was in 1837
and graduating Harvard you never could
have predicted Walden if you were at
1845 when he went to Walden you
certainly couldn't predict some of his
later works and so did to guess would be
kind of dangerous craft but thank you
for the question yes you mentioned at
the beginning of your talk that when
asked who they thought Thoreau was
people would say teacher rubber and you
felt right do you think being a writer
is his greatest gift I do and the reason
I say that because if thorough didn't
write as carefully and as well as he did
and I personally think he's probably one
of the greatest writers America has
produced you would be talking about
thorough the same as you talk about
charles lane and bronson alcott and
various other people who are doing
similar things that Sarah was doing one
of the things as I said in my talk is
that I realized how much they are
absorbed from other people there are
lots of people doing similar things that
he was doing people went often lived in
the woods by themselves they wrote about
it we don't read it today but they wrote
about it when you think about another
work like civil disobedience where we
think of thorough is the man who stood
on his principles and went to jail
Bronson Alcott did that about two years
earlier and there are other people who
are refusing to pay their taxes the
difference was when it happened to
thorough not only did it right about it
but she wrote about it in so so well in
a way that we are compelled we can't not
put the essay down or the book down and
so if there wasn't a writer first I
don't think we'd be here talking about
it today any other yes
Jess it's really striking when you when
you talk how how alive the kind of ideas
that sir ohrid wrote about are now in
society and how vibrant in a subset of
society the concept of living simply and
living deliberately is today I know that
when he was writing there were people as
you just said who had who were engaging
in civil disobedience or who were living
in the woods and there were
transcendentalists forming communities
but was there the same kind of
large-scale well well acknowledged a
subgroup of the mainstream world aware
of those ideas in the way that there is
now it's almost there's almost a kind of
fashion about currently about the ideas
of simplicity and rose over the case
then I mean there would be essays or
articles in in some of the mainstream
magazines but it's true that for
instance like the group that we refer to
as the transcendentalist had their own
journal the dial wasn't very widely
distributed Hawthorn's sister
sister-in-law Elizabeth Peabody I'm
editor journal called aesthetic papers
only had one issue before it folded so
the the means for getting those ideas
out there wasn't as easy as we would
think but on the other hand they did get
out there and somebody like thorough
that we tend to think of wrongfully as
is almost a failed writer because he
didn't have the wide distribution of
somebody like say Washington Irving or
net Nathaniel Hawthorne when he died he
had obituaries in every major newspaper
in journal people knew who he was people
were concerned about faculty he was gone
and his writings started going to print
and so I think there was an
understanding of who he was and what he
was trying to do but is true that the
day-to-day reader of the major
newspapers and journals would not
necessarily know all those things
any other questions well I certainly
appreciate you all coming and thank you
Jeffrey Cramer is the curator of
collections at the thorough Institute of
walden woods Walden a fully annotated
edition is published by yale university
press on the web at yale books com
[Music]